I don't agree with how he handles
National Security he focused on trade
with China but he did nothing about the
fentanyl flow he did nothing about the
fact that fentel has killed so many of
our Americans I don't think you should
praise Hezbollah I don't think you
should criticize Netanyahu when Israel's
down on her knees I don't think you
should congratulate the Chinese
Communist party on their 70th
Anniversary I think that when it comes
to National Security we don't praise
thugs we let them know where we stand
and we let them know they'll be held to
pay if they do anything against us
that's who I am this is Nikki Haley
fully embracing The Establishment Lane
in the GOP race and it's probably a
smart political move for her this is
Nikki Haley saying the ways in which
Donald Trump changed the Republican
party's position on foreign policy I am
going to change it back which is smart